hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully you
guys are all having an awesome holiday
so far since so many of you requested a
video for like all of my favorite shows
from this year this video is gonna be my
top 10 TV shows from 2014 there are a
whole lot of shows that I watch that I
don't do videos for but for the most
part the stuff you find on my channel
are all of my favorite things so here's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna name my top
10 shows and then for each of them I'll
just say my favorite episode of the year
and I'll have some announcements at the
end of the video just because there's
some special stuff coming next week
because it really is like the last week
of the year so let's do the thing and
just general spoiler warning for all the
shows that I do videos for so starting
with number 10
Gotham amongst the pantheon of new comic
book shows there's a lot of them
Gotham above all the rest had the
highest chances of sucking it's in that
Batman it didn't have costumes and its
central character was a little kid or
one of its central characters that's
like the Wesley Crusher syndrome I'm not
a huge fan of little kids on TV shows
that are supposed to be serious what
made me start to enjoy it though was
just how much embrace the campy aspects
of the Batman universe and when I say
campy I mean it goes to this really
self-aware of silly place that the
animated series and the Tim Burton films
went to visually there's a lot like
Chris Nolan in there too but my eyes are
always drawn to the Tim Burton type
scenes like when it gets a little
crazier look at this scene between
Edward nygma in this file clerk here
that he'd like to solve some bedroom
rails with forget the sexual comedy just
look at how they frame the shot in the
set design moments like this are really
what I love best about Gotham like if
you want to explain Gotham to your
friend don't say it's Batman without
Batman that probably like the worst way
to sell something tell them it's Gotham
Central it's a police procedural set
around detective Gordon in the Gotham
City PD I know the big question is is
why didn't they just call him Gotham
Central it'd be way easier the comic
book was super popular they had a lot of
great stories the answer is probably
because of rights issues I think a
stricter adaptation of the comic book
would have been a better show but the
stories and the characters in the comics
go way beyond what Fox is allowed to do
legally hands-down favorite episode of
Gotham so far is episode 9 Harvey Dent
I feel like you could show that episode
of your friends who are fans of Batman
and they'd still enjoy it because of
Harvey Dent and Nicolas de Gaston did a
great job with that character number 9
South Park
one of the few that I totally love that
I don't do videos for but ever since the
series went from 14 episodes down to 10
per season I feel like the quality has
gone way up
live-action shows take an entire week to
shoot an episode and then like another
two months of editing scoring
post-production animated shows can take
up to six months to produce South Park
writes animates and finishes each
episode in six days my favorite episode
of 2014 is [ __ ] magic although this year
there were like four episodes which I
thought were way better than almost
everything else on TV ever I think the
biggest reason for that is one they're
good writers they're topical they're
quick and they're informed and just
freaking hilarious you do not need to
sell South Park to your friends it's so
good it sells itself and they make it
available to watch everywhere for free
which is a big problem with premium
cable shows number eight agents of
shield I was already on board in season
one and I'll totally admit to watching
the show no matter how bad it gets like
I am on board for the riot I also watch
it just because it provides all the
extra context for the larger workings of
the Marvel movies one of the reasons
this season is so much better though is
because they debuted brand new IP for
the first time ever on screen that just
has me really excited for what they
might be able to do in the future
like if they can do Inhumans on TV now
what are they going to be able to do in
a couple years and I do think the show's
gonna survive I think it'll get renewed
for season 3 really what keeps me
emotionally connected to the show though
is Coulson it's his relationships with
the other characters he's the anchor of
the show with good cause I mean he's the
most experienced actor he's the most
connected to all the other characters in
the movies too I think just you know
from an actor perspective he does the
best job of selling the material
especially the weirder Marvel first
comic book II stuff and in real life he
is kind of like a spirit guide for all
the younger actors who are pushing
themselves Chloe Bennet as Skye for
instance I totally love what she's doing
this season but I just I want more of it
like there's so many characters you just
can't spend a lot of time with her good
news is the back half of the season
totally gonna focus on her with these
new inhuman powers and this new group of
people the Inhumans the movie that
Inhumans movie isn't coming out till
after Avengers 3 so right now is the
time to jump on board the ship my
favorite shield episode this year is
episode 8 things we bury it gives us
this amazing montage with our big
villain Whitehall and it's super
personal you have the ward brother
goin all Cain and Abel Whitehall
destroying Skye's mother in this great
performance from Hayley Atwell as Peggy
Carter and I will be doing videos for
Peggy Carter though weekly episode
videos that's gonna start on Tuesday
January 6th number 7 The Walking Dead
the energy from the show mixes so well
with the more pleasant emotions I get
from the other stuff i watch like arrow
for instance always makes me feel really
happy and excited after episodes but you
can't live on sugar alone so Walking
Dead is the perfect way to balance my
emotions
I always feel excited coming away from
episodes but it's like the type of
excitement you feel after you get in a
car crash like you're having a really
serious anxiety attack favorite episode
of the year is easily the season 5
premiere Carol wins everything just drop
the mic walk away number 6 Doctor Who
far and away my most beloved science
fiction series I did notice a lot of
fallout in the fandom between the 50th
anniversary special last year and the
regular series 8 episodes this year
doctor who always has this really strong
core fandom that both loves and hates
everything Steven Moffat does and will
tell you exactly what they think in all
caps in the YouTube comments series
eight was really polarizing like all the
new episodes that's part of the reason
why I love it so much good television is
television that it's worth talking about
and Doctor Who is not afraid to be
ridiculous like it vacillates between
really dark serious stories like listen
and relate silly moments like cousin it
in the TARDIS with the little fingers
sticking out seriously that was
ridiculous I'm just I'm much more
excited by new ideas than really amazing
action or huge twist in the plot so
female master and Capaldi's doctor made
for a great series there are so many
things I could say about Doctor Who this
year but I am gonna save some of those
for the bonus videos I'm going to be
doing next week the Christmas special
called last Christmas is December 25th
for those that don't know I mean it's a
Christmas special I'll try to get at
least a few Doctor Who videos up before
that so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
my favorite episode of this year not
including the Christmas special because
we haven't seen it yet is the caretaker
it's self-contained so you don't have to
watch it without knowing a lot about
Doctor Who and it's very personal very
good Danny pink story line number five
Legend of Korra so sad to see it end if
you never watched it they just had the
series finale and set off this same-sex
relationship
in the fandom the show in general is
really Western animation inspired by
anime which is funny because the term
anime is based on the English term
animation so it's like Western culture
influencing Eastern animation
influencing Western animation I'd say
this is probably the most well balanced
series in terms of female protagonists
female characters adult themes with
beautifully face-melting animation
seriously this is one of the most
beautiful looking series of the year
don't feel bad if you're totally crying
about it being gone now
favorite core episode this year was
definitely Korra alone episode 3 it's
such a fun deep scan of where Korra is
psychologically it features guitar and
it's the first appearance of Toph in the
new series so so many things to love
about it number 4 Sherlock I know it
seems like it's been so long since it's
been on but it's one of the best
examples of the genius baby that's born
when you combine some of the best actors
in the world with the best set design
and the best writing if you can't tell
I'm a huge Martin Freeman Benedict
Cumberbatch fan there's a very good
reason why they are the biggest actors
in the planet right now which is also
why it's so hard for them to make new
episodes that brings up an interesting
point
scarcity I think that's one of the
reasons why I enjoy it so much just
because there's only three 90-minute
episodes
there's no filler so you don't have like
really shitty episodes mixed in with
really amazing episodes
American television by contrast has like
20 plus episodes per season to fill so
the chances that everything is gonna be
amazing
is zero like there's no way every single
episode is gonna be amazing
my favorite episode of Sherlock this
year was episode 1 empty hearse it's
just like the right balance of drama and
comedy
sometimes it swings the comedy a little
bit more sometimes it's a little more
dramatic empty hearse hit that sweet
spot right in the middle if you really
wanted to get your friend into Sherlock
just first show them the Sherlock tag on
tumblr that's just so much fun just to
watch people interact with that for the
first time avoid the John Locke tag
though that's only for advanced fans
that can handle like the cringe-worthy
fan fiction and some of it really is
really out there so be careful but then
after they get the full blast to tumblr
in the face just show them series 1
episode 1 studying pink side note I will
be doing a few bonus Sherlock videos in
January they're gonna be filming the
25th
seeing Christmas special so I will
include new info as we get pictures from
the set I'll be sure to include liberal
spoiler warnings number three the flash
of all the new comic book shows this has
definitely been my favorite the new ones
that is the characters are the best and
the production crew has created the most
emotionally compelling and interesting
universe technically it is a shared
universe with arrow but the flash is
very different visually and totally
there are a few of its bigger characters
I still think need some work like iris
and Eddie but I think the back half of
the season is gonna spend some more time
with them
Harrison wells far and away my favorite
comic book TV villain of the year
comic book TV villain right now he is a
better villain than Rachele ghoul on
arrow who in the comics is one of the
biggest Batman villains of all time so
that says a lot for Tom Cavanagh I think
the reason for that though is largely in
the conception of the character and the
way he's written
he's inside team flash he's in every
episode and his motivations are very
complex like he's very evil but he wants
to protect the hero at all costs I don't
know if I can pick a single favorite
episode so far but episode 4 then the
crossover which is episode 8 in episode
9 are probably the best and if you
wanted to get your friend into the flash
just start the mode 1 or if they're like
a really big comic book person if they
read comic books they can handle the
crossover episode just start them on
that one number 2 arrow because Aaron
the flash are in this shared continuum
they share creative teams they share a
budget both shows are pretty equal in
terms of quality but arrow has just had
more time to develop its core characters
and build out the internal universe so I
connect with it emotionally a little bit
more than the flash and I would argue
that its lead Stephen Amell is both
amazing on and off the camera my own
experience with the show is a little bit
more meta like a little bit different
than the other stuff I watch just
because the actors and the network
itself like the CW network have engaged
with me personally Stephen Amell was
like the first big star to actually
reach out to me on social media to tell
me he liked my youtube channel it
totally blew my mind
I mean I'm just a fan of the show I'm
not like some huge big media personality
most actors don't even take the time to
engage with their fans but because the
captain as we so call him is so
connected to the fandom to his fans the
other cast members have started to do
the same thing and I think that's why
shows like Supernatural with
Jennsen and Jared survived a lot longer
just because they actually interact with
the people watching their show and they
care about them
favorite arrow episode this year was
definitely episode 9 the mid-season
finale it did the unthinkable
it had the balls to kill off its main
character whether whether or not he's
actually dead remains to be seen
funny thing about that though is Stephen
Amell is a big Game of Thrones fan so
you can think of this as like your
arrowed Ned Stark moment maybe Ned Stark
cross with the mountain versus the Viper
and my number one favorite TV show of
2014 easily Game of Thrones I feel like
nobody is surprised by this but it goes
without mentioning the quality of the
production and the constant
one-upmanship of each episode make this
the best genre show on TV right now
and when I say genre I mean sci-fi
fantasy horror you get the idea
remember how I said I really like Doctor
Who because it's so different from other
science fiction it's the same thing with
Game of Thrones and other fantasy shows
george RR martin is really the person to
thank for that i mean yes they are
changing things for season 5 but they're
only changing things to make it more
linear and to make it fit in 10 episodes
a year
it's that same situation with southpark
10 episodes means absolutely no time for
filler episodes I've rewatched the
season so many times I can't remember
what my original favorite was from the
year but I would say episode 8 is
probably my favorite right now the red
Viper versus the mountain one of the
best hours of television this year
period if you did want to get someone
into Game of Thrones like your friend
doesn't watch Game of Thrones already
just start them on season 1 episode 1 I
feel like it'd be too confusing to try
and start them whenever season 5 starts
and for those that are asking season 5
is premiering April 5th I've got a whole
bunch of awesome videos planned for each
of the episodes and some really cool
giveaways seriously season 5 is gonna
melt your face off it's gonna be awesome
so there were a whole bunch of shows
that didn't make the list like orphan
black or Constantine there's a lot of
good stuff that I watched but I mean
when you have to pick ten you have to
pick ten I always love it when you guys
leave me recommendations for new shows -
I know a lot of you want me to do videos
for the hundreds so feel free to keep
leaving recommendations and suggestions
in the comments and a couple
announcements for next week's videos
because the Doctor Who Christmas special
is happening next week on the 25th I'm
gonna do a couple Doctor Who bonus
videos starting next week I want to try
to get some Walking Dead and some other
Game of Thrones in there too but I will
be doing like some favorite you know
some
top ten lists for the next couple of
weeks the next new show that's
premiering is agent Carter that's gonna
be January 6 so look forward to those
videos I mean of all the new comic book
shows that are coming people are saying
that that's gonna be one of the best so
I am really curious about it right now
if you're on your mobile phone or on
your tablet there's new mobile links you
click on up here it's the same as the
links over here but click here to learn
about what's gonna be coming on Game of
Thrones Season 5 and click here to learn
the same thing for arrow what's gonna be
happening in 2015 thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I will
see you guys tomorrow
you